Body, Soul and Spirit. Now this is more of a larger overarching module in terms of
identifying categories within our personal development and journey as beings.
And we're going to unpack all the details of each of the sections coming up.
But the purpose of this, why go through this module, is because a lot of times we
don't know what category is what. And we can get confused, we can over focus on
one category which might be the intellect and the minds, and then we might, which is
a component of the soul, but we're not, we're feeling something's not right and
we're lacking something from the spirit. Or alternatively we could be obsessed
with everything to do with spirit. And the issue or the challenge or the way to
grow is actually do something in the physical level, the body. And so being
aware of this just provides us more of a larger scope of understanding of
ourselves. And also helps us at Eden Rise or in the associations or
foundations or anything things we're involved in. It helps us to have a bit
more of a reference point of the different dimensions to ourselves and
those around us. So enjoy this module all about body, soul and spirit.